laurent baffie costard destin
est ce que vous connaissez enrico macias
on voit bien sûr ce serait malheureux
vous pouvez me citer au moins une de ses
chansons bon bah j'en connais plein
multichances tomber alors attendez
américains parviennent à l'idée la pampa
leader enrico macias se connaît à
commercial géniale idée on dit ah non je
n'y aille bien moi je n'aime pas joli là
c'est bull yacouba siège l'a entendue
chanter bien qu'est-ce qu'ils font elle
veut dire moi je les connais toutes ses
chansons mes moyens énormes mais elles
ne viennent pas l'idéal istance validé
madame enrico macias oui je sais c'était
au moins une chanson d'enrico macias à y
en aura d'autres et moi une chanson
d'enrico macias enfants de tous pays à
l'encontre non à l'idée je veux dire l
idée dans la tête n'a pas l'idée
enrico macias qu'est-ce qui chantait
enfants de tous pays par sa collègue une
chanson
[Musique]
c'est stupide cupide qu'il n'y a pas une
idée comme ça pas l'idée madame enrico
macias est atteint et vous pouvez pas
invité mais d'après sur la voir ou non
par un coup d'oeil est citée moi une
chanson d'enrico macias manageuse aide
je peux même vous la chanter mais je ne
suis pas du tout dans le coup là
pourtant je sais moi une chanson
d'enrico réfléchir connaissez pas à quoi
j j non on n'a pas
déconner c'est tout je connais tout mais
je sais je le fais pas tu cries dérive
recul quand même ça ne vient pas là
incapable de me citer une seule chanson
du enfants de taupe et si tu allais que
je n'ai pas une rapide ses chansons
quand même c'est ridicule il est
connecté au début de tout pays c'est une
réponse vous préoccupez n'est que
matthias enfin de toupet de temps ici à
se ceindre est comme un siège de la
bourse
la star des stars et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux